- [Announcer] Climate change
is forcing us to rethink
our cities, making it
clear that the challenges
of upgrading urban areas
and addressing the threat
of global warming go hand-in-hand.
- Applying green construction techniques
at the urban block scale is one solution.
That's what we're prototyping
here at the Ecoblock
in Oakland, California.
We put together a remarkable team
of partners to tackle the problem.
- This first prototype
will retrofit 30 homes
in a lower to middle income neighborhood.
By sharing infrastructure
and sharing resources,
we can drive greater energy
and water efficiencies.
- Retrofitting existing neighborhoods
with the latest tools and technologies
is essential to greening our cities.
The Ecoblock offers a
systematic design platform
that can be adapted to
any city in the world.
- [Announcer] Behind the Ecoblock concept
are well-established retrofit strategies
to reduce energy use,
greenhouse gas emissions,
and water consumption.
Costs will be offset by long-term savings,
while retrofitting will increase comfort
and offer security against
the effects of climate change.
Installing solar panels on roofs
will turn the block into
an urban solar farm.
The energy will be stored communally
and distributed to homes and electrical
vehicles via DC microgrid,
managed by smart controls.
EV charging stations will be
installed around the block,
enabling the community to share
EVs, e-bikes and e-scooters.
The energy efficiency gains will reduce
electricity consumption by over 80 percent
and lower carbon emissions close to zero,
a valuable feat given that residential
buildings and private fossil fuel cars
emit over 50 percent of
U.S. greenhouse gasses.
Rainwater will be collected,
purified, and used
for washing machines and
new low-flush toilets.
Efficient showerheads and
taps will be installed,
and gray water will be used for gardens,
decreasing water usage
by at least 50 percent.
Eventually, black water from toilets
will be recycled for irrigation,
further maximizing water efficiency.
New permeable sidewalks and pavement
will solve storm water problems
and recharge the ground water.
- The key to the success of this project
is engaging the community residents.
The city of Oakland is
proud to partner with them
in this experiment in
urban sustainability.
- The Ecoblock is a new model for creating
resilient and sustainable
cities in California
Ecoblocks can provide local investment
in green jobs and green infrastructure,
revitalize our urban communities,
and help low to middle income
families improve their lives.
- The Ecoblock confirms California's
commitment to concrete, scalable solutions
to climate change.
Our goal is to build a
model that can be replicated
and scaled across California,
across the United States,
and around the world.
- [Announcer] Keen interest from Europe,
Africa, and Asia confirms the
promise of greening cities
by means of community scale
Ecoblock retrofitting.